[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
r b singer r kelly's attorney on an
attack behind bars
why he says the singer not the attacker
is paying the price
also um for all of us it is a
very tense and emotional time two
officers are shot
as protests erupt over a grand jury's
decision
to refuse to criminally charge officers
for shooting and killing her
plus a 13 year old with autism shot by
an officer
stop get on the ground knock it off we
break down
disturbing body camera video and a
foul-mouthed defendant
tests a judge's patience
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin as usual
authorities in iowa announcing four
arrests in the suspected murder of an
african-american man found burned in a
ditch
stephen vogel is charged with
first-degree murder cody johnson roy lee
garner
and julia cox are charged with abuse of
a corpse among other
counts authorities say they do not
suspect the killing
was a hate crime and now to kentucky
where two police officers have been shot
and wounded during protests over a
decision there not to charge a group of
other officers
with shooting and killing briana taylor
earlier this year the interim louisville
police chief says one suspect is in
custody
and that both officers are expected to
recover
a grand jury refused to indict a group
of officers for shooting taylor
but did indict one officer for shooting
into neighboring apartments
the police killed briana taylor when her
boyfriend fired back at the cops who
were executing a no knock warrant
the boyfriend grabbed his gun assuming
the officers were intruders
the mayor of louisville pleaded with
protesters to remain peaceful
violence will only be a source of pain
not a cure for pain and we know that
violence is never
the answer our community is hurting
many see brianna taylor's case as both
the tragic death of a young woman
and the continuation of a long pattern
of devaluation and violence
that black women and men face in our
country
as they have historically well the
question obviously is what do we do
with this pain there is no one answer
no easy answer to that question but i do
know this
violence is not the answer and
destruction is not the answer
public safety and the work for racial
equity and justice
can and must coexist that's the goal
that we're working toward
creating equity in our city for everyone
in our city police arrested 127 people
protesting the news of the indictment
law on crime daily's brian buckmeyer has
more about the grand jury's decision
brian
three officers fired the night of the
shooting at brianna taylor's house
only one is facing charges and not for
her death
two of the officers miles cosgrove and
john manley
are off the hook and on paid
administrative leave but the grand jury
decided officer brett hankinson
should be charged with three counts of
first degree wanton endangerment
for firing shots in neighboring
apartments hankinson was fired from the
police force this summer
obviously this is a tense and stressful
time for our officers they're dealing
with
the protest activity it's been a very
emotional time for our officers in our
city
as we go through the attorney general's
opinion
for all of us it is a very tense and
emotional
time i think our officers are in good
spirits given the conditions that uh
we're in in the city right now of course
they're concerned for the well-being
of our city of our other officers and
and for themselves and next in the
brianna taylor case is a federal
investigation here to tell us more about
that is law on crime daily's terry
austin terry
erin you know the fbi began its
investigation in may
and that federal probe continues even
after the grand jury indictment from the
state
fbi agents are now said to be looking
into allegations
the officer who drafted the no knock
warrant gave
false information to a judge concerning
supposed
suspicious packages being delivered to
taylor's home
former federal prosecutor gene rossi
says the brianna taylor case is being
handled
by the civil rights division
and the civil rights division of the
department of justice is going to work
with the fbi
and they're going to do an incredibly
thorough investigation
you can guarantee that the uh the
murder or alleged murder in ferguson
missouri years ago
they investigated that thoroughly uh in
in this case brianna taylor's case
they're going to do the same thing
there'll be a federal grand jury uh
that'll be secret of course
uh but i gotta tell people it's gonna
take uh
months maybe years before they either
issue a final report
or decide to press charges it's not
going to take a one month or two months
it's going to be a long process
so terry it sounds like ultimately the
federal investigation
might provide a few answers that the
state investigation was relatively
silent on
well that's right i think we have to do
what gene said and that is be
you know patient as far as this case is
concerned there are a lot of component
parts remember
we had this civil settlement the 12
million dollar settlement and
much of that involved police reform
making sure they kept in contact with
the community
now you have these criminal charges
which many people were not happy with
but then we also have the fbi
investigation so a lot of moving parts
and it will take some time to resolve
all of the various issues
what i'm pleased about with the federal
pro brian is the
more myopic look at what was going on
with the process to secure the warrant
because that seems to be the root of any
possible evil with this case
i mean yeah and that's definitely
something that we're all interested in
seeing but at the end of the day i think
many of us have lost
faith in this process as brianna
taylor's case has been investigated and
there's so many other changes
except no one's left responsible for her
death
well there's some responsibility with
the civil case but many people aren't
happy
with that being enough should it been
have been further brian
there is no responsibility for the civil
case the officers in the city of
louisville
did not admit guilt that's a part of the
simple case no one is saying they did
anything wrong when it came to the death
of brianna taylor and i think that is
what's really the sticking point for
many people
true true 12 million judgment though
certainly talks in its own sense
doesn't talk loud enough for many i
believe that's the situation 12 million
police reform but still you have a
police department where no one is found
guilty for killing someone
certainly a guilty count would force a
lot more reform than just
talk of reform an attorney for r kelly
is shedding light on the r b singer's
life behind bars
kelly awaits state and federal crimes
trials
sex crimes trials that is and was
attacked behind bars
attorney steve greenberg tells law and
crime in an exclusive interview that
kelly must remain in his cell for 24
hours a day
except for rare phone calls and other
matters greenberg criticized the
authorities for claiming kelly is no
longer in danger because
they moved his attacker to another
facility
well i say that that's not going to
solve the problem because that one guy
made threats those threats were brought
to the attention of the jail
officials and they did nothing just as
new threats have been brought to their
attention
and they're going to do nothing uh it's
one thing to say we took action
after the fact but what are they doing
to protect him beforehand
and he shouldn't be punished you know
one of their solutions
for a time was to put him in solitary
confinement because
he got beat up he got punished it's a
badge of honor to some guys this guy
who who beat him up and beat him up
quite severely
uh we just got the video it's awful what
occurred
uh this guy who beat him up is spending
the rest of his life in jail
there's no downside to him he was a
multiple murderer he shouldn't have been
housed in the same area as robert and he
was so the jail officials really
failed him there but it gets the larger
issue which is
he shouldn't be locked up anyway as
we've been saying all along he's not a
flight risk
he's not a danger to anybody he should
be out they can't give him a trial date
and it is it's just a colossal mess
greenberg bolted some of the core
accusations against kelly which could
end in a 10-year
minimum mandatory sentence just in
federal court just in illinois
and greenberg railed against the process
kelly faces
you know it's terribly frustrating when
you know that you are 100 percent
correct
but someone like robert kelly is being
treated completely different
than anyone else who was in the same
situation
anyone else who had these charges and
didn't have the notoriety
wouldn't be in custody wouldn't have to
wait indefinitely for a trial
they can't give him a trial because he's
famous they are doing trials now
but they can't accommodate the media
they can't accommodate the public they
can't accommodate
the number of witnesses they can't
accommodate how many jurors it will take
all of this is being held against him
and that's just not right that's
un-american
full steam ahead we want a trial date we
want a trial date as soon as possible
and we want to proceed to trial and
still ahead on law and crime daily
prosecutors make another play in their
case involving nfl owner robert kraft
and
the woman accused of helping kill her
wealthy boyfriend's wife scores her own
small legal victory long crime daily
continues after this
a legal victory is all but official for
new england patriots owner robert kraft
florida prosecutors have filed court
papers to drop prostitution charges
against the nfl owner
kraft was charged in connection with a
sting operation at a massage parlor
where authorities say
some patrons were paying for sex acts
the police
installed and monitored hidden
surveillance cameras inside private
areas of the spa
but judges at the trial and the appeals
court levels ruled that the tactics
violated patrons rights to privacy
because the officers did not minimize
their intrusion
on lawful conduct to connecticut now
where a judge has eased pre-trial
restrictions on the woman accused of
conspiring
to murder her boyfriend's wife michelle
traconis can leave her house
and no longer has a curfew but she must
still wear
a gps monitor and cannot leave the state
without permission from the authorities
draconis and her boyfriend fostulos were
accused together of conspiring to kill
jennifer doulos feldas dulles committed
suicide before trial
draconis's attorney has been trying for
months to get the client out on bail and
to ease her bail restrictions here are
some of the arguments
from a previous hearing and her
attorney's reaction
i also know her mother who's a
psychologist in florida has moved up in
his living with her she's a
she has a practice but she's been
staying with her
up until now because she's not allowed
to even go
shopping the amount of money the parents
posted all their property
if she were to flee they would lose
everything so
i think that's something that court can
take into consideration i know for a
fact
i spoke to the bail bondsman he has
secured the entire 2.1 million
property owned by both of his parents
father is a doctor a cardiologist
mother is a psychologist
today was just about loosening the
restrictions on her house arrest
michelle pled not guilty today on the
most recent charges
and asked for a jury and until i've
reviewed the material that were just
given to me and that's why i brought
this large
briefcase i have no other comment
because i don't know enough to say
anything other than what i've said
before
michelle is innocent of these charges
and we plan to fight them
through the courts thank you very much
do you share any reaction to the death
of forty stullos from
mr ponis um no i would say that that's
not appropriate
so terry the attorney they're not
wanting to discuss the photos dulo
suicide which was shortly before that
hearing but this has been a long fight
saying the parents have 2.1 million
dollars in assets that they can use to
secure her cooperation with the criminal
process
is this move to give draconis more
freedom leading up to a trial rare or is
it common
well i was shocked frankly aaron because
she faces some serious charges i mean
conspiracy to commit
murder is about as serious as you can
get and tampering with evidence in
connection with that murder is something
i would think they would want to keep
her under
house arrest it's the least they can do
considering the fact that
she has been facing all of these very
serious charges
brian they know where she is with the
gps monitor so presumably she's not
going to tamper with any more evidence
if she's out walking around but let's
talk about the bond deal here
millions of dollars of property securing
the freedom and the cooperation not
everybody gets that chance
no not at all i mean everyone gets some
sort of bail or bond and bond is
typically
you give up a percentage of cash and the
rest is secured
by some sort of property or some sort of
object with our car or boat whatever may
be
but the peculiar part about this is that
there's no real change of circumstances
which is usually the standard by which
you change
restrictions or bail or bond but somehow
hey
i tip my hat to the defense attorney it
seems like he did a good job he won a
quick argument here we'll continue to
watch that case and later on tonight
cockroaches spiders and other disturbing
items arrive in the mail for a
massachusetts couple
and four ebay employees are in trouble
with the law over
the move but first the defendant who
mouthed off to court personnel and who
just couldn't stop
swearing how long before the judge loses
her patience
that's coming up right after this
[Music]
a florida defendant caught on camera
with a rather foul mouth
time now for a look inside the
courthouse from court cam's dan abrams
we're in the miami-dade bond court good
afternoon
i'm judge mindy glazer i'll be presiding
today over the bond hearings
today she'll see dozens of defendants
you were arrested for
retail theft and i'll appoint the public
defender for you
but one in particular is sure to stand
out
the defendant is sherry lynn who's
facing charges of felony battery and
resisting arrest with violence
[Music]
lynn appears remotely and is represented
by a public defender
and from the very first question have
you ever been treated for any mental
health issues
it's clear lynn is in no
mood to be in court i'm sorry ma'am
how's it going okay well i'm a little
busy right now
take another look at yourself judge
glazer initially finds the behavior
amusing but she's not about to let it
continue
i'm just trying to help him he's trying
to help you and please don't use
profanity or trying to disrupt my
courtroom because i don't want to be
forced to hold you in content
all right he's trying to mr sanders and
i'm ordering that you stay away from
cynthia cuba do not have any contact
with her and you must stay away from her
homeless place of business
as to the other case who is this cynthia
cuba
tell me um you literally try to hit with
the pliers
the other cases
have a nice day ma'am let's try and get
you into the hospital lin's ordered to
pay a
fifty dollar fine and undergo a
psychiatric evaluation
earmuffs folks earmuffs court cam a long
crime production airing in its entirety
on the a
e network and when we come back here on
law and crime daily the police shooting
of a 13 year old why the teen's mother
is calling for a change in tactics
that's next on law on crime daily
federal prosecutors say a group of ebay
employees is planning to plead guilty to
mailing cockroaches and spiders to
bloggers who were critical of the
popular auction
site the four former employee defendants
live in california
but are poised to admit to cyber
stalking for sending the creepy
creatures to a couple in massachusetts
a total of seven ebay people were
charged including the now former senior
director of safety and security
and the now former director of global
resiliency
the couple also received other
disturbing items
court documents say the ebay employees
also levied
internal threats to burn one of the
bloggers
to the ground and now to salt lake city
where police have released body cam
video of officers shooting a 13 year old
boy with autism
three different investigations are now
looking into how the shooting unfolded
it started when the boy's mother called
911 asking for help
she told the officers that her son was
autistic and was having a breakdown
the boy remains hospitalized nearly two
weeks after police pulled the trigger
9-1-1 what is your emergency hi
and the lyon county sheriff's department
they shot my dad and killed him in his
front yard this year
and so my son has severe severe uh he
does not like cops
at all um and so that's why we need a
mental health worker it's super
important
because i i really um he's sick
the boy's mother told officers her son
had sensory disorders and had previous
run-ins with the police
she also warned them he might have a bb
gun
sure it's a bb gun i don't know if it's
a bb gun i don't know if it's a pellet
gun i don't know if it's a prop weapon
because my other son but you don't know
if it's a real gun either it's
i don't believe it's a real gun i don't
believe it's a religion so unfortunately
we have to kind of treat them all
as if they are i know um what is it that
you want from us tonight we need him to
go to the hospital i need him to go to
the hospital i cannot get in there on my
own
officers discussed calling superiors but
then confronted the boy
a chase ensued and ended with at least
one officer opening fire
the body camera footage tells the story
we are going to show it now
but the video is disturbing and you
might want to look away toward the end
here
honestly we can call sergeant and tell
him the situation because i'm not about
to get in a shooting
because he's upset
122 restricted here we got a pursuit
male and all black
running southbound
stop get on the ground knock it off back
to you guys
coming back to you
get on the ground get on the ground
on the ground now on the ground
hey show me your hands show me your
hands
i don't feel good show me your hands
come on mama
the boy's parents say he's severely
injured and is being treated for
gunshots to his shoulder his ankles and
his intestines terry the boy's mother
called for
what's called a cit or a crisis
intervention officer
do you think that this rolled out the
way that the mother
thought it would i mean it seemed like
there were just a lot of red flags in
that 9-1-1 call
i've got to tell you aaron as a mother
this is the worst nightmare you could
possibly have
knowing that your child has autism
and that he needs to be handled with
care asking the police
not to send police officers but to send
someone
who can give him some medical treatment
who can be a crisis intervention and
person who can help him go to the
hospital it is
horrible that this is how the police
responded and you know frankly he could
have easily died there were about
11 rounds shot they're very lucky that
he's alive he will never be the same
and frankly i think there's a lawsuit
waiting to happen
right here you know that's highly
possible i agree with that terry
it's really hard to watch this footage
brian but i think we have to watch it
because this is what can happen
if the police are called mistakes can
happen miscommunication can happen it
could turn into a mess
the only thing i disagree with that
aaron is that there was no mistake here
this is how
officers operate when they they were
correct they said
if you don't know if it's a gun or not
we have to operate as such officers
should not be entangled in these
situations
she didn't you don't get to control what
the officers do and don't do once they
get there and if they feel like their
life isn't threatened they're going to
act accordingly so your big issue is
even calling the police well we
appreciate the insight here we're out of
time on long crime daily we'll see you
here next time
for our discussions
i'm dan abrams and this is the law and
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
today
[Music]
you